que toutes les réalités possibles existent réellement.
Le jeune physicien, Max Tegmark aussi,
qui pense que toutes les structures mathématiques existent,
et que l'existence mathématique vaut l'existence physique.
Donc, nous avons ce multi-univers immensément riche
qui inclut toutes possibilités logiques.
Maintenant, en adoptant cette manière métaphysique de s'en sortir,
ces physiciens et philosophes
reviennent en réalité à une très vieille idée
qui remonte à Platon.
C'est le principe de plénitude ou de fécondité,
ou la grande chaîne de l'existence :
la réalité est aussi remplie que possible.
Elle est aussi opposée au néant
qu'il est possible de l'être.
Nous avons donc maintenant ces deux extrêmes .
D'une part, nous avons le néant pur,
et nous avons d'autre part cette vision d'une réalité
qui inclut tous les mondes imaginables .
La réalité la plus pleine
ou le néant, la plus simple des réalités.
Mais qu'y a-t-il entre ces deux extrêmes ?
Toute sorte de réalités intermédiaires
qui incluent certaines choses et en excluent d'autres.
Un de ces réalités intermédiaires
est, disons, la plus élégante sur le plan mathématique,
elle évite les éléments inélégants,
les asymétries laides, etc.
Certains physiciens vous diront
que nous vivons en fait dans la plus élégante des réalité.
Brian Green est dans l'assistance, je crois.
Il a écrit un livre intitulé « L'univers élégant ».
Il prétend que l'univers dans lequel nous vivons
est mathématiquement très élégant.
Ne le croyez pas. (rires)
C'est un vœu pieux. J'aimerais que ça soit vrai,
mais il m'a avoué l'autre jour
que l'univers est vraiment laid.
Sa construction est stupide,
il a beaucoup trop de constantes de couplage
et de rapports de masse arbitraires,
et de familles superflues de particules élémentaires.
Et qu'est-ce que c'est que cette énergie sombre ?
C'est un machin fait de bouts de ficelle.
Ce n'est pas un univers élégant. (rires)
Et puis il y a le meilleur des mondes possibles?
au sens éthique.
Soyez sérieux maintenant,
car c'est un monde dans lequel des êtres sensibles
ne souffrent pas inutilement,
dans lequel il n'y a ni cancer infantile ni holocauste.
Voilà une conception éthique.
Bref, entre le néant
et la plus pleine des réalités,
existent plusieurs réalités spéciales.
Le néant est spécial. C'est le plus simple.
Et puis il y a la réalité la plus élégante possible.
C'est spécial.
La plus pleine des réalités, qui est spéciale.
Mais est-ce qu'on ne serait pas en train d'oublier quelque chose ?
Il y a aussi les réalités minables,
les réalités génériques,
qui ne sont aucunement spéciales.
Elles sont aléatoires, disons.
Elles sont infiniment loin du néant,
mais aussi infiniment loin de la plénitude.
Elles sont un mélange d'ordre et de chaos,
d'élégance mathématique et de laideur.
Je décrirais ces réalités
comme un foutoir infini, médiocre, incomplet,
une réalité générique, une sorte de rafistolage cosmique.
Et ces réalités...
Y'a-t-il une divinité dans ces réalités ?
Peut-être, mais elle n'est pas parfaite
comme la divinité judéo-chrétienne.
Elle n'est pas bienveillante ni omnipotente.
Elle est peut-être malveillante à 100%,
mais seulement efficace à 80%.
Ce qui décrirait plutôt bien le monde que nous voyons autour, je pense. (rires)
Alors, je vous propose comme solution
au mystère de l'existence,
que la réalité dans laquelle nous existons
est une de ces réalités génériques.
La réalité doit bien être quelque chose.
Soit elle s'avère n'être rien,
ou tout à la fois, ou quelque chose entre les deux.
Alors, si elle a une particularité
comme d'être vraiment élégante ou vraiment pleine,
ou vraiment simple, comme le néant,
cela demanderait une explication.
Mais si c'est une de ces réalités aléatoires, génériques,
elle ne requiert pas d'explication plus avancée.
Et en effet, j'aurais tendance à dire
que c'est la réalité dans laquelle nous vivons.
Voilà ce que nous dit la science.
Au début de la semaine,
nous avons appris une nouvelle excitante
sur la théorie de l'inflation
qui décrit une réalité infinie, arbitraire et vaine
qui serait comme de la mousse de champagne
jaillissant d'une bouteille en continu.
Un vaste univers largement inoccupé
avec de petits ilots de magie, d'ordre et de paix.
Ce scénario d'inflation
a été confirmé par des observations
faites par des radiotélescopes en Antarctique.
Ils ont examiné les traces des ondes gravitationnelles
juste avant le Big Bang.
Je suis sûr que vous en avez entendu parler.
Je crois donc qu'il existe des preuves
que cette réalité est celle dans laquelle nous sommes coincés.
Maintenant, qu'est-ce que ça peut nous faire ?
Eh bien... (rires)
La question : « pourquoi le monde existe-t-il ? »,
la question cosmique, fait en quelque sorte écho
à une question plus personnelle :
« Pourquoi j'existe ? Pourquoi vous existez ? »
Vous savez, notre existence paraît hautement improbable,
parce qu'il y a un énorme nombre d'êtres humains génétiquement possibles ;
vous pouvez calculer ça
en comptant le nombre de gènes, d'allèles, etc.
Un calcul approximatif vous dira
qu'il y a environ 10 puissance 10 000 humains génétiquement possibles.
C'est à dire entre un gogol et un gogolplex.
Et le nombre total d'humains ayant existé
est de 100 milliards, peut-être 50,
soit une part infinitésimale,
donc nous tous, nous avons gagné
à cette incroyable loterie cosmique.
Nous sommes ici. D'accord.
Dans quel genre de réalité voulons nous vivre ?
Avons-nous envie de vivre dans une réalité particulière ?
Et si nous vivions dans la réalité la plus élégante possible ?
Imaginez la pression existentielle qui s'exercerait sur nous
pour vivre à ce niveau, être raffiné,
pour ne pas gâcher l'ambiance.
Ou alors, si nous vivions dans la réalité la plus pleine ?
Alors notre existence serait garantie,
parce que chaque chose possible
existerait dans cette réalité,
mais nos choix seraient dénués de sens.
Si je me débats dans un cruel dilemme moral,
et décide de faire ce qui est juste,
qu'est-ce que ça change ?
Puisqu'il y a une infinité
de versions de moi
qui font aussi ce qui est bien,
et une infinité qui font ce qui est mal.
Donc mes choix sont dénués de sens.
On ne veut pas vivre dans cette réalité-là.
Quant à la réalité spéciale du néant,
nous ne tiendrions pas cette conversation.
Alors je pense qu'à vivre dans une réalité générique médiocre,
il y a de bonnes et de mauvaises choses.
Nous pouvons cultiver les bonnes choses,
et réduire les mauvaises,
ce qui nous donne un certain but dans la vie.
L'univers est absurde,
mais on peut s'inventer un but, et celui-là est plutôt bon.
La médiocrité générale de la réalité
répond bien à la médiocrité
que nous ressentons tous au plus profond de nous.
Je sais que vous la ressentez.
Je sais que vous êtes tous spéciaux,
mais vous êtes aussi secrètement médiocre, non ?
(rires) (applaudissements)
Vous vous dites peut-être que ce puzzle, le mystère de l'existence,
c'est du coupage de cheveux en quatre.
Vous n'êtes pas stupéfaits par l'existence de l'univers
et vous n'êtes pas les seuls.
Bertrand Russell a dit :
« Je dirais que l'univers est là, un point c'est tout. »
C'est un fait brut.
Et mon professeur à Columbia, Sidney Morgenbesser,
un grand farceur de philosophe,
à ma question : « Professeur Morgenbesser,
pourquoi y a-t-il quelque chose plutôt que rien ? »,
a répondu : « Oh, même s'il n'y avait rien,
tu ne serais toujours pas satisfait. »
Donc... (rires) ...bien.
Donc vous n'êtes pas stupéfaits. Je m'en fiche.
Mais je vous dirais une chose pour conclure,
et je vous garantis que vous serez surpris
parce que ça a surpris les plus brillants esprits,
les gens merveilleux que j'ai rencontrés à cette conférence TED,
et cette chose la voici :
Jamais de ma vie je n'ai eu de portable.
Merci.
(rires) (applaudissements)